Hello.
My name is Hannah Dickinson
and this is “Cheers to you”.
Where I'm kicking off my first
round of the weekend
by cheersing
to all the people
and stories
that encourage me to drink.
Cheers to you Japanese Princess
for renouncing your royal status
to marry a commoner
but upholding the world
tradition of women dating down.
Cheers to you 50 Cent
for buying 200 tickets
to Ja Rule's concert
so the front row will be empty.
Or cheers to you Ja Rule
for finally selling 200 tickets.
Really.
Finally.
Cheers to you Jenna Jameson
for breastfeeding your daughter
for 18 months.
That's honestly nothing
compared to the 18 years
you breastfed your co-stars.
Cheers to you Don McLean
for dating a woman
49 years younger than you.
I can't imagine anything worse
than having sex
with a 74-year-old except ...
paying my own rent.
Does anyone old watch
Comedy Central?
Speaking of old men,
cheers to you
Ben & Jerry's for putting out
a flavor protesting
Trump called
Pecan Resist.
Now that two more old white guys
are throwing their nuts around,
everything's fixed.
Cheers to you Tomi Lahren
for defending
Meghan Kelly's heinous
blackface comments.
But who will defend
your heinous bangs?
It's not political,
it's aesthetic.
They're terrible.
You went from a ten
to like a six.
And you don't believe in
feminism, so I can say that.
Cheers to you Lime for recalling
your electric scooters
in fear they'll catch fire.
Makes sense because every time
I ride one, it's (bleep) lit.
Be sure to check out
the rest of our show
Monday through Thursday,
Every Damn Day.
Cheers.